I've I have got my own makeup um which
is like theatrical makeup so it is a lot
lot thicker um where I've been doing it
so long I kind of know someone's died of
cancer because their skin will be yellow
um I kind of know but so once I know
once I've I've gone in and I've viewed
who who I'm doing um I I do have there
are some products that you can spray so
you get an
even um you know an even coverage if
they've got because depending on how
they died you their blood would be so if
they died and fell on their face their
blood so that you can never get rid of
that so I've got makeup to cover that
but if some families want their own
makeup I can do that too and I do do
some of their own makeup um but usually
I do try and cover it up so you know
there is more of a
coverage a lot thicker than what we
would use